[Música]
si los animales pudieran hablar que nos
dirían si pudiéramos preguntarles y
decirles que necesitas que contestarían
ellos yo se los pregunté
pero antes les quiero contar antes de
darles la respuesta quieren contarles
una historia cuando era niño me
encantaban los animales los amaba y tuve
muchos tuve perros gatos serpientes
peces me encantaba tenerlos
también me encantaban las artes y
dibujaba esculpía terminé dedicando mi
vida más este lado de las artes aun
cuando mi mamá me decía ser veterinario
aunque si eres veterinario nos vas a
llevar tú cuando se esté muriendo un
animal tú vas el que esté llorando en el
paciente termine siendo diseñadora
industrial y construir una empresa pero
me seguían encantando los animales
resulta que un día en la televisión y un
vídeo de cómo vivían los cerdos en las
granjas como los transportaban como los
mataban yo era muy cercano a mis
animales yo tenía mi perro y cuando vi
ese vídeo y cerdos colgando de sus patas
para que les pudieran clavar un cuchillo
los oí llorar que se quedó grabado en la
cabeza vi como los separaban de sus
madres y fue muy duro para mí porque de
algún modo yo conecté y yo veía a mi
perro y lo veía igual eran super
parecidos tal vez algún día ustedes
puedan verlo ya lo hayan hecho
ver lo parecidos que son los diferentes
tipos de animales a los perros a los
gatos que hoy si consideramos como
cercanos a nosotros
y entonces me deprimí lloré y dije yo he
sido parte de esto pero estoy provocando
con mi dinero con mi consumo y yo estoy
matando a sus animales y yo no sé si
ustedes conocen una frase que utilizan
los cristianos que dicen que haría jesús
ellos lo utilizan cuando tiene una
disyuntiva cuando no saben qué decidir
dicen que haría jesús los hagamos de
cuenta que yo algo parecido dije que
necesitan los animales y así como ellos
se pueden pulseras para ello me puse una
pulsera y dije que necesitan los
animales y todos los días me preguntaba
que necesitan en ese momento dije dios o
si yo les pudiera preguntar y fuese en
el momento en el que les pregunté qué
necesitan de mí
y la respuesta fue sí no nos hagas daño
unos mates respetarnos y se me ocurrió
no comerme los no vestirme con ellos
investigue qué pasaba con ellos y pues
tampoco fui espectáculos con animales y
puedan seguir común en la empresa iba
creciendo la empresa pero yo seguía
amando a los animales y me seguía
preguntando pues todos los días porque
tenía mi perro y era vegano que no sabía
que era vegano porque en ese tiempo pues
todavía no eran famosos los veganos y
entonces pues solo no me los comía ni ni
ni los usaba trataba de no lastimarlos y
sucedió que me di cuenta que aunque yo
no me los comiera aunque yo no los usara
ellos seguían sufriendo porque yo me iba
a una plaza de toros pero la plaza
seguía matando animales en los rastros
se seguía matando dije algo más tengo
que hacer
y les volvió a preguntar que necesitan y
la respuesta fue convence a los demás y
entonces dije como los convenció que
resulta que hay organizaciones que lo
hacen en hacer que organizaciones que
educan y que protestan y que muestran la
realidad están viviendo a los animales y
era muy feliz haciendo eso soy penoso
por ejemplo no me gusta hablar en
público pero lo hago porque los animales
no necesitan y no me gustaba quitarme la
ropa pero me la quitaba y me tiraba
sangre encima para que la gente supiera
qué era lo que ocurría con los animales
pero me seguía preguntando que necesitan
porque resulta que la educación era
lenta que la gente no se da cuenta y
aunque se diera cuenta pues no decía
después de darse cuenta después de ver
que le pasa a los animales bueno los voy
a dejar de comer ya les voy a dejar de
usar ya no no porque está rico porque es
cómodo porque hoy tengo carnita asada se
va hacer o no se va a hacer la carnita
asada y entonces pues no lo dejaban
dije esto es muy lento animales que
necesitan necesitamos que lo haga rápido
porque porque nos están matando por
millones y es que se me ocurrió no yo
pensaba bueno hay muchas formas de
hacerlo rápido nos robamos a los
animales y los guardamos a todos lo que
no nos cabía ni nos iban a meter a la
cárcel estos no era la solución dije
bueno cuando la gente no se quiere poner
el cinturón de seguridad le hacen una
ley y se lo tiene que ponerlo cuando la
gente no quiere dejar de fumar en frente
de los que no fuman y hacen una ley y lo
deja de hacer y quizás las leyes van a
obligar a la gente a hacer cosas es lo
más rápido que puedo hacer por los
animales
y entonces yo trabajaba en una
organización y nos pidieron en la
organización que fundó leonora
animanaturalis trabaje ahí y aún nos
pidieron hacer una campaña que se llama
circo sin animales tenemos que pedirle
una celebridad que posaran que dijera yo
quiero un circo sin animales lo hicimos
varias celebridades y lo más importante
bueno el más conocido marco antonio
régil que siempre dice que sí a todo lo
que tenga que ver con ayudar a animales
y entonces se lanzó en otros países si
yo decía no pero aquí no tenemos que
hacer una ley entonces tardamos más que
conseguir los abogados conseguimos gente
que supiera hacer leyes biólogos que nos
explicaran los campos de información con
el gobierno no tenía ni idea cuántos
animales habían y dónde estaban pero
hicimos la propuesta de ley
tocamos la puerta de legisladores en el
país y nos abrieron una en querétaro
y llegamos nosotros tenemos esta
iniciativa de ley que queremos que
prohíba el uso de animales en los hijos
y tenemos todos estos artistas que le
apoyan no le interesa la iniciativa
seguramente lo dijo hay artistas yo
quiero no funcionó no solo para él
funciona para el congreso y en querétaro
en 2013 se prohibieron los animales en
los circos por primera vez
y después de eso se viene una bola de
nieve porque nos llamaban de estados y
había que viajar para legislar y había
que dar entrevistas y había que
cabildear y había que hacer un montón de
cosas había que ser diseños y más
artistas venían y querían ayudar
entonces hizo algo gigante
pero yo seguía teniendo la empresa
y al hacer todo esto ya no le pude poner
atención a la empresa y la llevé una
crisis terrible
terminé viviendo en de mi oficina porque
mi familia se tuvo que ir porque aparte
de todo esto pues en los cirqueros les
había molestado porque los vivían muchos
de ellos de sus animales y veían que les
estábamos cambiando su estilo de vida
comenzaron las amenazas y en redes
sociales con cualquiera de nosotros
tenía mi familia a mi hijo y de repente
empezaron a rodar las fotos no y este
que cuida tu hijo y amenazas fuertes y
pues se fueron porque pues ni había
dinero ya y estaban las ordenanzas
entonces se fueron y yo vi viene oficina
y sacaba todos los días desde abajo de
un sillón las cobijas y me dormía y
comía lo que tenía para comer en una
sartén eta me bañaba a jicarazos porque
no había regadera y me preguntaba ahí
que necesitan los animales
pero en mi hijo que necesita y que
necesita mi familia y que necesita
méxico y que necesito yo
y después de mucho pensarlo la respuesta
fue para empezar yo necesito ser feliz y
soy feliz ayudando a los animales y
ayudando a los otros que necesitan mi
hijo un papá que le dé ejemplo un papá
que le enseñe que se puede ser feliz
haciendo lo que uno quiere que se pueden
lograr las cosas y que se puede cambiar
el mundo entonces dije pues al [ __ ] la
empresa
y vendí lo que tenía y empezamos a hacer
este movimiento fundamos la organización
animal heros que la intención es llamar
a la gente decir tú puedes hacer el
cambio que tú quieras y tenemos mamás
trabajando con nosotros que mientras
tienen a sus hijos y ya que se durmieron
trabajan un ratito tenemos abogados que
en sus oficinas de repente nos dan
tiempo y hacen leyes somos gente común
cambiando cosas y hemos logrado prohibir
las corridas de toros en coahuila
hemos logrado también tipificar el
maltrato animal como delito este es que
quien maltrato el animal se vaya a la
cárcel en muchos estados en colaboración
también con mucha gente que trabaja en
esto estamos trabajando por detener la
reproducción de delfines en cautiverio
hemos logrado muchísimas cosas gente
común
como cualquiera de nosotros
yo los quiero invitar a que se hagan
preguntas aquí la pregunta d
qué necesito yo para ser feliz el apoyo
en una pulsera en un tatuaje en algo que
les recuerde todos los días que necesito
para ser feliz
si pueden los invito a hacerse una más
qué necesitan los demás de mí
y yo les puedo decir con una experiencia
propia que es lo más feliz del mundo
vivirá ayudando a los demás
quizá la felicidad esté detrás de una
simple pregunta como qué puedo hacer por
los demás muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]